one of my favorite sayings is that
anything that you build with passion and
whites chaos can you tell us how that
happened with the film well it goes
again to the trust and you know what can
you trust one of the one of the
modalities that I work with and I
brought the leader of it into my film
Mike both of aura soma it's a very
beautiful energy called color therapy
for the soul but each energy color that
we work with as in aura soma which means
light body has a theme and one of the
main themes is the only constant in life
is change and so the more that we would
go after something I want it to be you
know look a certain way we had to adapt
to change over and over the film that we
have today really bears very little
resemblance to what we started out with
in the beginning and one of the primary
changes for me was I wasn't going to
share my story in the film I was going
to be a talking head talking about
spiritual concepts and all the things I
had learned from the head and here I go
and start to make a film about journey
of the heart and I realized to be
authentic to be fully Who I am I needed
to share my story and I needed to go
through some pretty deep personal chaos
in order to say you know Here I am
comfortable happy to be here in going
through this process of change and it
wasn't easy in it that's one of the
reasons it took a number of years to do
this film how long did it take to finish
well it was three years from the
beginning and tell when we were really
down a little bit less than three years
and throughout that process I had to go
deeper into my heart I encountered the
work of Colin tipping and went through
radical forgiveness and then our
directors he shares on in the film he
was diagnosed with cancer and so we had
a quite a long pause in the production
when he went through that process and
many people suggested I fire him and get
somebody else and I said you know what
this is not what this project is about
you know he is part of our family and
we're going to be with him to see this
through and
and we took that opportunity myself and
co-producer Donald Backstrom to really
do our own internal work so that we
could you know see this through to
completion what would you say to other
filmmakers are artists who have such a
set way they want something to go
whether it's they want to come to LA and
be here in the strata of Hollywood by a
certain time and it doesn't happen what
would you say to people that have a
certain way they want to control it it
doesn't work out well I would say to
people who want to control her outcome I
just say good luck because you can't I
mean you just have to the more that and
this comes to a personal experience the
more I tried to control who was going to
say what or when the filming was going
to occur or how the final project
project was going to look the the more
chaos going back to your earlier
question that was invited into the
project because then nothing was working
and so you know the more when you find
yourself where the sets not coming
together the people are late it's really
about looking inside yourself as the
leader of the project what is it that
I'm holding on to that has to be this
way in the minute you let it go
everything comes together and I've had
that happen over and over and over again
you